l'histoire d'amour entre les yvelines et
paris nice continue pour la douzième
année consécutive le département va
accueillir la course au soleil en mars
prochain
le parcours a été officiellement dévoilé
ce mercredi 6 janvier
et cette année c'est la ville de saint
cyr l'école qui ouvrira cette édition
2021 pour une étape à travers les
yvelines le départ de l'étape sera
au niveau de l'école de l'école
militaire après on fera une boucle de 2
60 70 km à parcourir deux fois et donc
l'arrivée sera sera jugé en faux-plat
montant
dans le coeur de ville pas très loin de
la ligne de départ mais en coeur de
ville en léger faux plat donc en venant
de versailles donc un clin d'oeil aussi
au château de versailles en passant
et puis une belle arrivée ou et c'est ce
que disait en faux plat montant
le lendemain le peloton s'élancera de la
commune de watteville sûrement science
dans le nord du département pour une
étape de 188 km en direction du loiret
une grande première pour ce village de
1000 habitants situés dans le parc
naturel régional du vexin français très
bon tableau noël voilà même si noël
vient de passer une journée c'est
vraiment un très très beau cadeau de
noël et et on va se faire un plaisir
collectivement et moi individuellement
un grand plaisir pour celui mars si on
va mettre tous les moyens on peut on
peut avoir et notre envie je trouve que
c'est bien la démonstration que c'est
pas que les grandes communes dans les
yvelines qui font les yvelines les
petites communes les communes moins
peuplées une participent
la commune pourra voir des stars du
cyclisme français et international le
slovène primoz sro glitch deuxième du
dernier tour de france a déjà annoncé
vouloir ouvrir sa saison par ce
paris-nice 2021